superhero movies present us with
larger-than-life heroes who overcome
impossible odds to save the day the real
heroes though are the actors who don the
outputs to bring these comic book legend
still life because the experiences
aren't always so pleasant here are some
examples of actors who have put on their
super suits but didn't particularly
enjoy doing so Andrew Garfield as the
famous webhead in both amazing
spider-man films her fields gave us a
different look at Peter Parker but what
Garfield didn't want us to get a look at
was his spider-man outfit and how
uncomfortable and unflattering it was I
knew there were paparazzi taking
terrible unflattering shots of my you
know everything said Garfield the corny
Digital Spy the whole point of wearing a
mask is you feel free and you can be
whatever you want and you can be witty
but then he was made uncomfortable by
the fact that the onlookers were getting
butt shots of him from many many
different angles that's one way to get
your spider sense tingling chadwick
boseman as the first live-action version
of Marvel's black panther and Captain
America Civil War Chadwick Boseman had
to squeeze into a black cat suit in
90-degree weather blows been talked to
cinema blend about how certain stunts
would be physically demanding because of
the suit every time they add a part I'd
be like you mean I just gonna cut off my
ears look like okay let me figure out
how to breathe like that
he also talked about how he had to get
into a Zen space in order to get through
the difficult stunts since he'd have
sweat rolling down his body and was
unable to scratch hitches you'd think it
would have been easy for him especially
with those vibranium claws Scarlett
Johansson Black Widow might have had
read in her ledger but Scarlett
Johansson had sweat in her socks
Johansson said in an interview with
Nightline about the first Avengers movie
quote was so hot I would wring out my
socks at the end of the day that's gross
but also it's understandable considering
the fact that her Black Widow costume
was like a wet suit it wasn't Pleasant
in the heat in fact that got so hot that
she actually hallucinating for a bit
while filming a fight senior Johansson
also compared the multiple costume she
had to tires because her stunts would
wear each one down until she needed to
replace them pulling off all those her
occur on toes could have been easy on
those stitches Malin Akerman as
sweatiest some actors get in their
costumes Mullen Ackerman's experiences
in the Silk Spectre costume for Watchmen
are wholly different the skin type black
and yellow suit shows off her physique
while looking pretty bad
ass but according to Maxim Ackerman said
the latex costume smelled terrible quote
I thought it was really hot at first
then I tried it on and I thought it was
really uncomfortable when you take it
off it smells like a human condom said
Ackerman and with those words we can
never see Watchmen again without gagging
just a little bit olivia munn while
donning costumes cannon power
superheroes is another thing altogether
to actually get into them olivia munn
who played Psylocke and x-men apocalypse
revealed on Conan that it took a bit of
help to get into her characters I caught
a [ __ ] costumes to be more specific
it took the help of two women and a lot
of Lube to get that outfit on you think
that having to do that every time you
shoot a scene was embarrassing enough
but the first time she got on set with
the veteran x-men actors she actually
popped a crotch on the suit whoops
Rebecca Romain in a 2003 interview with
Entertainment Weekly Rebecca Romain
talked about how hard it was to get the
mystique make it applied for the filming
of x2 x-men United the process involved
four women and a little under eight
hours effectively souring romance mood
as time went on when I first took this
on they told me it would take ten hours
of six hours the worst part however was
the fact that she was naked under all
the makeup while everyone else got to
wear outfits at one point director Bryan
Singer came in to her temple she was
bent over a chair and getting her a
crack touched up she might have been
painted blue but we're willing to bet
her face was pretty red margot robbie
she may quite literally slay in her
Suicide Squad hot pants but murderer
Robbie was definitely not a fan of them
while a lot of folks are making her
Holly Quinn out to be an overtly sexual
piece of eye candy Robbie said that
Quinn likes the shorts because they're
sparkly and fun and not because she
wants guys opting her but as Margo no I
don't like wearing that I'm eating
burgers at lunchtime then you got to do
a scene where your hose down and soaking
wet in a white t-shirt and so clinging
you're self-conscious about it Robbie
told in New York Times Ben Affleck our
newest Batman has made it known that
he's not a huge fan of the báb suit he
wore in Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice while many a fanboy would love
to Don the cape and cowl al flick called
it the most humiliating ridiculous thing
in the world according to Total Film
this is because the bad suit was really
a motion capture suit that allowed for
greater range of movement he even gave a
nickname of the suit and called it his
visual effects pajamas we understand
that he might have felt it was
embarrassing to wear the off
because it didn't make him feel badass
like that man but at least there were no
bat nipples thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know which super suit you think looks
the most uncomfortable